during these last days of Ramadan
Al-Aqsa compound becomes a beacon of
quiet a place where Palestinians Love to
Worship or just spend the day
it's been four years since Omaha was
lost here
we have forbidden to come here unless we
get a permit and it's not easy last time
the soldiers came in and there were
clashes with the youth we had to leave
it was also Ramadan I get sad when I see
the soldiers beating people I can't
explain the feeling inside
in the corner of the compound
restoration work is underway fixing the
stained glass windows that were broken
during an incursion by Israeli forces to
evacuate the mosque
video shows how they first break the
windows and then Lobster grenades at the
worshipers below fragments of colored
glass flying over their heads Israeli
forces come in with their ladder climb
onto the rooftop and in a matter of
minutes the windows are shattered now to
repair any damage is much trickier
because even if Jordan is the custodian
of the site Israel controls the type and
the amount of raw material allowed into
the compound at any given time
was detained for six hours for
attempting to fix a tile in the
courtyard he's the director of the
restoration committee
if I need tiles cement anything I notify
the occupation forces that are at the
gates for security reasons but each time
there are obstacles the first answer we
get is to wait until they evaluate that
can take an hour several days or
sometimes our request is refused
this is not the first time the windows
need to be replaced the ottoman era
Originals were destroyed in a fire in
1969. but The Replacements were also
broken during prior raids it will now
take six months to repair each of the
three Windows destroyed this month
in a few days access for non-muslims
will resume Ultra nationalist Israeli
Jews will return to the grounds here
surrounded by police in full riot gear
the count Palestinians are enjoying now
could end at any time picking up the
pieces restoring what has been broken
has become an all too familiar part of
the religious practice and daily life
for Palestinians here Al Jazeera in
occupied East Jerusalem